hey
congratulations thanks how are you I'm
doing fantastic how are you doing I'm
doing well thank you listen Jason I mean
Creator writer EP star you're wearing a
lot of hats nowadays how does a you know
what is a Moment Like This feel like
well it feels great I have to say credit
where credit is due um Bill Lawrence and
Brett Goldstein uh you know they brought
me along on this beautiful ride I'm
lucky to be able to help out in all
those capacities but um yeah I just feel
really lucky to be working with such a
fantastic group yeah it's amazing is it
like a terrifying feeling knowing it's
going out into the world or is it just
like a sense of accomplishment you know
uh it's somewhere in between I don't
really get terrified anymore because
weirdly I'm uh I'm 42 years old now so
I've been doing this for 25 years all of
a sudden it was so strange
um but you are in this you are in this
moment where you've made something that
you think and hope could be really
really good and now you're gonna find
out if other people also think it's
really good
um which is exciting and scary and it's
like it's like you're going on a first
date with the world
oh that's exciting that's a good way to
put it right the first day of the world
I'm sure it'll go great I'm sure it'll
go great we'll see so yeah so like
listen
we got it we gotta get to it Harrison
Ford like come on Jason come on he's
such a big fan of mine uh it must be so
exciting for him I'm sure
yeah no I mean it's it's just
unbelievable it's the kind of thing
where until he actually arrived I didn't
think that it was true and
um now I find myself acting across from
one of my idols and a legend and the
most generous thing about Harrison is
that he makes you feel like a peer
you know which is uh which is really
special
that's incredible I cannot even imagine
it's like they always say don't meet
your Heroes but like I feel like this is
this is an amazing thing right like what
is the most incredible part of working
alongside someone like Harrison Ford
there was a moment when uh I I was like
running a little bit of late to set or a
little late to set
and uh so I threw on a jumpsuit I don't
wear a jumpsuit very often but I was
like I don't want to pick out an outfit
I gotta eat the sets I put on a jumpsuit
My Hope being that I would arrive to set
and no one would see me I would just get
in my trailer and put on my costume and
when I got to my trailer Harrison Ford
was waiting outside to run lines so I
have to get out of my car and face
Harrison Ford in a jumpsuit and I'm
really embarrassed about it and it keeps
kind of eyeing me up and down as we're
talking like are you looking at my
jumpsuit Harrison and he said I sure am
kid and uh and I was like really
embarrassed then the next day
Harrison Ford showed up to set wearing a
jumpsuit
to uh have some camaraderie I have a
picture of me and Harrison Ford in
matching jumpsuits and that's all I need
for the rest of my life this is amazing
and I'm gonna need this picture case I'm
like 100 percent
amazing well thank you so much
congratulations on this series I'm so
excited for the world to see it hey
that's so kind of you thanks